freedom of the press is only guaranteed
when you own the press
communication breakdown pause for the
message wake up every station is
identification global syndication is the
shaping of the nation abc disney nbc ge
murder gets foxy and with a hint he owns
a pen the cameras are sold by a coke by
ford getting broke getting bored
from the earliest days freedom of the
press was what defined america thomas
jefferson helped write the declaration
of independence believed a free media
was essential for a free nation saying
were it left to me to decide whether we
should have a government without
newspapers or newspapers without a
government i should not hesitate a
moment to prefer the latter
that was in 1787 today our newspapers
seem to be fading in importance in a
multimedia world that is largely owned
and controlled by a handful of large
media
corporations i think we're probably the
most media dominated society in the
world
jeff cohn worked in major media now he's
one of the industry's fiercest critics
half a dozen corporations
own and control most of the mainstream
media in our country so if you're
looking at who rules america or who owns
america
it's the same people that propagandize
to america the press and the outlets
that report news or convey information
are just a small slice of vast media
empires producing entertainment products
that also sell a way of life based on
consumption
when you look at who's on the boards of
media corporations they're also on the
boards of u.s oil companies
and they're on the boards of u.s
military contractors so
trying to study who owns america you're
really also these are the people that
own the media we don't have a state
media
but in some ways it's very much like a
state media it's the corporate state
if this is true then we can say that the
american media doesn't just report news
as we'll see it's not independent of the
system but a pillar of it it reinforces
the world view and defends the interests
of those who rule america
30 years ago 50 companies dominated
american media now it's down to six here
are some charts on media ownership that
illustrate this concentration
with new global digital enterprises like
google facebook and twitter growing in
importance worldwide us-based media
became a transnational force
the u.s media companies are themselves
owned in large part by hedge funds
mutual funds and finance companies barry
james dyke is an asset manager who has
studied media ownership the research
which i've done is unequivocal and i
kind of stumbled into this is that
the the media companies the major media
companies i.e the disney's the cbs's the
news corporations
all of them this is all public documents
is that they're all owned actually owned
by
mutual fund companies the majority
shareholders are owned by mutual fund
companies so um
and also they also get a lot of the
revenue from these companies so you're
never going to see any consistent
criticism about these fund companies are
these companies investigated by the
media no they're not
are they responsible
to the public in some way are they
accountable do the public really know
what they're doing the public really
doesn't have a clue
they really don't know what they're
doing he has documented his findings
with charts in his own book the pirates
of manhattan
well then people are not going to begin
not getting the truth
but there is a lot of coverage
especially of politics that's often
treated as a sporting event with an
emphasis on poll numbers and election
results mary boyle follows media
coverage of elections for common cause
what about the role of the media is the
media helping to strengthen our
democracy do you think it's helping to
divide us
well i i think that's a great question i
i think that um
you know there are a couple of things
going on there obviously you've got kind
of cable channels that are
you know in different camps and they are
not showing different points of view
you've got fox news showing the right
you've got msnbc
showing the left
and so with a setup like that you you
have americans that are just kind of
tuning in to the channel they want to
listen to that you know kind of
expresses their views and and you're not
seeing kind of a mix of an opinion a
debate anything like that you've also
got you know the shrinkage of of the
media
you've got less coverage of what's going
on and i think this is particularly
concerning
more around kind of state-based and and
local politics
where there's even less coverage of of
what's going on in politics
but even as the world is known for its
diversity american media is not
editorially and ideologically the power
elite tends to reflect the views of the
government and the people who shape its
views
dissenting politicians like congressman
jesse jackson jr have a hard time
getting their views heard
who owns the media
how the media is translated some of the
moguls and the titans of media and
industry
are part of the problem
they shape a narrative for the american
people
a narrative that ultimately leads
millions of people to vote for
candidates based upon the narrative that
they shape based upon the talking heads
that they control
and
those
americans tend to vote and tend to
engage the system on the basis of that
which they hear media is a significant
part of this problem
historian eric foner agrees he says it's
not just political bias at work but what
the media as a business feels it's
forced to focus on to attract ratings
and revenues
somehow
that idea of of power
uh behind the people in office
is not really in our media very much
it's not really in people's minds very
much they personalize politics their
personalities combating each other but
they don't look at who's behind the
scenes well you you're quite right that
the the media focuses on personalities
you know and and and often the quirks of
personality clinton's sexual excapades
or whether obama was born in the united
states or not or romney and his cars and
whatever you know is not paying taxes
and many other things those are not
totally unimportant issues but maybe
it's the nature of the media today
in and of itself in that it it you know
it has to go for the quick news
deep investigative reporting is not
emphasized as much as perhaps it was in
the past and um you know you got to sell
papers and scandal sells papers
um
personality sells papers celebrity sales
papers
so uh you're right that the you know the
the larger nature of how the system
operates tends not to get emphasized as
much it's not even understood by many
people well it's hard to understand this
is a very large country over 300 million
people a very very complicated economy
and political system so it's it's
difficult to understand exactly how
things operate but i think
but but i think you know in a certain
sense the anti-government sentiment
which is rife in this country which is
generally associated with the right wing
is also a response to the feeling
it's an encoate feeling it's not an
analytical feeling but it's a feeling
that government is
aloof it is not responsive it does not
really represent the people it
represents some very particular
interests and that sense is pretty
widespread in this country
media watch groups are also concerned
about the lack of diversity within the
media that makes it unrepresentative of
the country it serves in racial ethnic
and gender terms
the unwritten
credo of the new york times is do not
alienate those for whom we depend
on for money and access chris hedges was
an award-winning journalist for the new
york times
an american media star
and that means the power elite
and the financiers who advertise
so
but but it's
it's expandable i mean you have you have
at least in the positions that i was in
the possibility
uh to do
journalism not that there aren't you
know restrictions or constrictions there
are
um and not that they can't be punishing
hedges work is still very respected but
he believes that much of the press is
ultimately a charade that covers up for
power more than covers it especially
when reporting on elections
because the political theater i mean the
personal narrative of the candidate it's
all irrelevant it's meaningless uh and
and people you know we still play the
game look every uh totalitarian country
i covered had elections they all play
the charade i mean even east germany did
and
and that's the charade we play and when
we have a compliant corporate media that
pretends that that charade is real
so i think
uh the problem is that the illusion
still remains so powerful
but people are changing but the illusion
is still so powerful that people confuse
where power actually exists
how does the new york times cover the
power centers that many people say rule
america chris spanos edits the new york
times examiner that monitors the
newspaper's content every day he
believes the paper has become an
accomplice to the power elite
the new york times as an institution is
almost like a mini nation and in the in
the correspondence the the op-ed writers
the editors they're almost like
diplomats and how they they they carry
themselves and their own self-importance
and in the way that they communicate
with other politicians and diplomats and
they are very influential would you say
that they're a disseminator of ideology
in america not just of information
absolutely they're they disseminate a
very particular ideology and that their
readership is primarily
managers um and and people who make
around over 90 thousand dollars a year
and and so they cater to a managerial
perspective and and so they they have a
pro management when they're discussing
labor relations they often have a pro
management view a pro-business view
financial journalists like stacy herbert
and max kaiser found that many
pro-business views in some media outlets
were often uninformed as they told me on
a radio show
from december 2008 so well after the
collapse of bear stearns lehman brothers
the mark is tumbling a thousand points
in a day
and the head of bbc world news business
said
and we had a 10 episode contract do you
think the financial crisis will last all
the way through these 10 episodes
so in other words the people actually in
charge of planning the coverage are are
very uninformed themselves well the
mainstream media are themselves deeply
in debt you know the news organizations
have become entertainified and and to
compete they take on enormous amounts of
debt so the bankers they don't want to
uh to to insult their creditors uh
because they might cut off their lines
of credit so they don't have they're not
unbiased in this regard in any stretch
of the imagination you see this most
spectacularly with the new york times
they their their coverage of the wall
street is pitiful to my world one reason
the press is so pro-business is that
they are themselves businesses the
people who run media companies
increasingly pay themselves
huge salaries and bonuses the same way
that bankers do says barry dyke
les moonves i couldn't believe he made
59 million in 2009 and he racked up it
was just as close the other day that he
made close to 70 million in uh 2010 and
that's the head of cbs that's the head
of cbs
but you're saying that all of them
are really running their businesses as
if they were banks
i mean that's pretty good that's bank or
pay i mean 70 million dollars a lot of
money in anyone's book and that's what
they're getting paid
so the the the media companies are
really part of this whole system of who
rules america they're they're part of
these interconnecting interlocking
relationships with financial
institutions there's no question there's
no question about you get the the media
companies which are huge it's part of
the empire you get the media companies
you get the bankers of course
you have the your massive you know
unions okay you have um
uh other uh factors as well but those
the media is definitely part of it and
the asset managers that's exactly it the
corporations that own the u.s media and
own u.s television are very wealthy and
very powerful and the people at the top
of the news networks get paid an awful
lot of money
i have never earned anything close
to the amount of money i earned in the
one year i worked where general electric
was my boss at msnbc so what i think
happens is a self-censorship where
the people who rise to the top
have learned how not to rock any boats
and they know if they do rock boats they
will lose their huge salaries
newspapers like the new york times the
washington post and the wall street
journal tend to frame a deeper narrative
that tells us what we should believe
matters
they set the agenda that influences what
tv news programs also cover for example
they don't focus on any quality and
class differences says independent media
executive brian roulet
they don't talk about the working class
and part of it is it's like the the idea
that you know they promote this idea
that you know if you buy a lottery
ticket you could win right so you're
already thinking that maybe you could
win so if you're in the if you're in the
working class or you're part of the
working class that's unemployed
you still have this hope that somehow
you're going to go into the middle class
there's been very little attention paid
to class
i mean you were saying that the media
really doesn't discuss this they don't
really
highlight class differences in america
they're much more comfortable talking
about racial differences or ethnic
differences
at the same time in their business
practices they're very conscious of
demographics what class
are they attracting upper class how to
cater their advertising how to sell it
no they go i mean you know the internet
is a perfect example the only thing
where they're constantly slicing and
dicing who you are so they know exactly
how much you make so they can pitch what
kind of products to you but that's
that's this whole sort of
madness of the consumer society that's
been created by modern capitalism but
the the key thing i think that you're
getting at is is that even though there
is a reality of class a working class in
this country and a ruling class or a
boudoir class
people have been trained not to think in
those terms so they don't even know who
they
are some networks like fox news owned by
rupert murdoch seem to be more
comfortable presenting a right-wing
political line they have helped shift
many media outlets to the right there is
a school of thought that says we should
have given the citizens of baghdad 48
hours to get out of dodge and flatten
the place then the war would be already
over and we could have done that in two
days that may be so but old media is
being eclipsed by the new says george
scribner the vice president of digitas a
company that comes up with digital
strategies for big companies and studies
how affluent consumers now drive
marketing in an era of growing economic
inequality
the one thing that's different now is
that the media is owned by everyone
you know there's there's the only thing
that's kind of leveling off the dollars
to some extent
is that
everyone has access to twitter everyone
has access to blogging and there's this
new kind of
fast and fluid coalition building like
occupy wall street what street was one
example of that
the arab spring wasn't an example of
that so in some ways kind of the
there's the check there's a new check
and balance i don't think that's
necessarily changing the restructuring
of income and wealth but i do think
there's another trip switch
that that might help us when things get
too bad so the digital media in a way is
where democracy is today it's not in
politics it's not in big business it's
not in big money that's true i think
that's well said
there is some debate on how free the
internet really is given corporate
control and government censorship but it
does make possible more interactivity at
the same time media attention still
tends to revolve around the political
elite with authority even if that elite
doesn't necessarily have the power to
shape priorities or impose policies
but when you talk to ordinary americans
many of them feel it's totally fair
they're seeing different points of view
they're seeing people who are critical
from time to time
you know they see the media as the
liberal media in some instances i was in
the soviet union and it was we were
always raised in this country that
that's pure propaganda and frankly it
was very ineffective propaganda because
they never pretended to have two points
of view they would have some one point
of view saying how great things are but
in our country
propaganda is really effective because
they have the appearance of debates the
united states of america will not permit
the world's most dangerous regimes to
threaten us
jeff cohn says that just as americans
were misled about iraq before the war
they are being misled today about iran
he pointed to a study about iraq before
the american invasion that found that of
some
393 people who were interviewed on all
the networks only three were anti-war
because almost everything we knew about
iraq before the invasion turned out to
be false and almost everything we're
learning today about iran
is uh not accurate and we you know we
went to the new york times a couple
months ago where they said that the
international atomic energy association
has put out an assessment
that the nuclear program in iran has a
military objective
and the fair this media criticism group
went to the times and said which report
is that we've never heard of it the
times knew they'd made a big error it
was a prominent error
they removed the sentence from their
website but they refused to correct the
error
it's not just wars that get
propagandized media does not often cover
the people behind the scenes who run
things says william hartong who has
written about the military industrial
complex
you would think
there would be some independence
in the journalism on this issue but in
some cases reporters have even said to
me well you know i can't go after the
pentagon harder or the companies harder
or this nexus of influence harder
because
uh this company is a big advertiser in
the paper and we'll get pressure you
know if we do those kinds of stories so
we'll do stories about the war in
afghanistan we'll repeat what the
president has to say on an issue but
there's not really a lot of interest or
resources put into investigating these
kinds of connections
david swanson who also writes about
military policy agrees
well the corporate media in the united
states is integrated with the
military-industrial complex some of the
same corporations are making profits
from both
there are two major political parties
that don't have much disagreement on
this topic so it's not a topic for
debate no matter if 90 percent of the
public is upset about it it's not
acceptable news
michael clare who's investigated the
destructive power of oil and gas
companies says the same is true when it
comes to that industry
the media doesn't cover this for the
most part in fact the media is largely
in league because of the advertising
dollars that the oil and gas lobby
provides they're very heavily dependent
on
advertising revenue so they're very
careful in what they say
big business a wealthy and frequent
advertiser in the media is often not
scrutinized by the media that was the
case in the financial crisis as sheila
krumholz of the center for responsive
politics
so
these are complicated issues the issues
are are difficult to understand on a
good day and they seem again very arcane
and
and unimportant to the average american
so it's possible that that some media
were
laboring away trying to explain why this
was critical information that the voters
need i think a lot of blame though can
be laid at the at the feet of the media
for the financial collapse ultimately
what we do know is that it's critical if
there if there's any uh perfect uh
scenario that shows why transparency and
paying attention scrutinizing the the
powerful players and what they want and
what they're doing to get uh get their
way
the financial crisis is is that perfect
example it shows us how important
transparency is because significant
wealth demands significant attention
together we can give you and your wealth
the wings to soar
[Music]
goldman sachs wealth management
at the same time media has become so
pervasive online and off on tv and on
our mobile phones that many americans
say they are becoming victims of
information overload the more they watch
the less they know
for sure information overload is i think
a
serious threat
to
democracy because it doesn't work if
people aren't vigilant nobody's going to
hold
members of congress accountable for you
you have to
take
you have to
make sure that you're heard
i think there's also the the sense that
because there is this
tension and some would say healthy
tension
between
concern about uh protecting the process
democracy and government from money's
undue influence versus protecting
freedom of speech
and privacy
nobody wants
to
censor information we want our
representatives to have
all the information even if it's coming
from deep pocketed corporations unions
or trade associations very narrow
interest we just want to make sure that
they are doing their job to seek
alternative perspectives even if they're
coming from groups that have no power
and have no money media criticism tends
to revolve around what's being covered
and not covered and not on the way media
narratives shape how we think and what
we think about that's the power of media
and why it is now among the forces
ruling america
coming up in the next episode of who
rules america money now controls
politics
and you look at our system as so broken
nobody in their right mind would try to
copy our system if they wanted a real
democracy
next time on who rules america
you